So, was macht denn Unity Media, außer wieder rumspacken?
Scheint ja zu funktionieren.
Poggers.
Haben nur ein paar Frames getroppt.
Das hält doch in Grenzen, oder?
So, ich muss noch mal kurz aufs Klo.
Und ich muss mir eine Hose anziehen.
Also, ich habe eine an.
Also, ich soll als wäre ich nackig.
Ich habe eine an.
Aber ich habe eine kurze Hose an.
Das wird mir langsam zu kühl hier.
So, und dann muss ich noch mal kurz aufs Klo.
Und dann bin ich da.
Zwei, drei Minuten geht es los.
Weil es geht eh nicht so viel heute.
Ui.
Ja, wie gesagt, Leute.
Ich muss mir kurz noch mal eine Hose anziehen gehen.
Und.
Ich habe nur eine kurze Hose an.
Ich ziehe eine lange Hose an.
Und ich muss noch mal kurz aufs Klo.
Und dann bin ich am Start.
Zwei Minuten.
So, ich bin ich, ich bin ich Kacken-Chat.
Wie kommt ihr denn da drauf?
Was habt ihr denn für Fantasien wieder?
Nee, ich war heute nicht aus dem Haus.
Ich wollte ja eigentlich mit meiner Maske auch gucken, ob ich bei der Bank Geld abheben kann.
Aber ich bin heute nicht aus dem Haus gegangen.
Den ganzen Tag nicht.
Ich habe es, ach doch, doch, stimmt nicht.
Das Einzige, was ich geschafft habe, ist, ich habe es geschafft, in Wäschestände auf Balkon, nicht auf Balkon, was weiß ich, auf die Terrasse zu stellen.
Wieder rein zu rollen.
Das war es.
Mehr habe ich nicht gemacht heute.
So, ich muss mein PP-Gabort wieder starten.
Sagt mal, Chat.
Ihr kennt euch, ihr kennt euch doch aus.
Der Chat kennt sich doch aus.
Und zwar kennt ihr eine gute Übersichtsseite und Kalender, wo man sehen kann, wann welche Technik-Events im Jahr sind, wo neue Sachen angekündigt werden.
Wusstest du schon, dass Battlefield 5 aufgegeben wurde von DICE?
Ja, das haben wir uns schon ein bisschen am Montag, äh, nee, Sonntag drüber lustig gemacht.
Ich habe ein bisschen meinen Browser abgekackt.
PP-Gabort, wo ist das PP-Gabort hin?
Wow.
Eieiei, was ist mit meiner VM los?
Monka, Monka, F, Press F, Alter.
Oh, jeje.
Dead.
Rip.
Tf, was hat der für Schmerzen?
Okay.
Alle Firefox, alle, alle Firefox immer killen.
Haben sie wenig RAM?
Äh, passt doch.
Okay, jetzt funktioniert's.
Okay, was, was auch immer.
What?
Oh, hat sich mal unsere IP wieder geändert.
Jetzt haben wir die 132.
Ah, yes.
Exzellent.
Ach so.
Ich habe immer noch das Auto.
Oh, warte, ey.
Lull.
Lull W.
So.
Bevorzugst du, was, was bevorzugst du eigentlich für ein Smartphone?
Ich habe ein iPhone.
Ich hatte noch nie ein Android-Smartphone.
Ich habe nur jede Menge Android-Tablets.
Also ich habe den Vergleich schon, aber ein Android-Smartphone hatte ich noch nicht.
Das liegt aber auch daran, weil ich mir noch nie,
ich habe noch nie, ich habe noch nie, ich habe noch nie, ich habe noch nie, ich habe noch nie, ich habe noch nie,
Was ist das für ein Video?
Warum das Internet in Deutschland so schlecht ist?
Okay.
Heißt das, das wollen wir gleich gucken, oder was?
Können wir machen.
Das, das.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich kenne den nicht.
Ist das einer, der rumschreit?
Dann gucke ich mir das Video nämlich nicht an.
Schreit er rum?
Ich kriege immer Anfälle, wenn, wenn irgendwelche Leute, vor allem Let's Player, einfach so anfangen sollen, rumzuschreien.
Nee, der schreit nicht.
Okay, wunderbar.
Schau dir mal kurz den deutschen Computerspielpreis-Livestream an.
man auch ist er ist er gerade ist er gerade alle wasser kohle moment wo ist
die musik musik kurz bis leiser man ok eine eine minute grinsch leute ok und
dann dann ist gut da war aus einem juli grinsch zum
live stream ist ein live stream live stream auf der games da was hier die
spielzeit nicht als begrenzt im überfluss abzubauende ressourcen zur
verfügung zu stellen das ist ein innovativer ansatz erst
recht das zeichnen wir heute abend aus der deutsche computer was zum für das
beste debut 2020 geht an
studios und application systems heidelberg an was long ging ja vielen
dank die sitzen alle daheim wegen corona
oder was was ist das taugt das game auch hier die steam bewertung sind doch
ganz gut scheint doch zumindest was die bewertung angeht zurecht geworden zu
haben ich meine ich habe zwar keine ahnung was da eigentlich passiert
es ist doch eine gute chance dass man sich die auf die lage bringen kann
eitel game da fack heidel game eitel games das war's für den friseur er spielt
ja auch in die games mittlerweile ne ne das kann ich mir angucken können sie
nicht so können sie dann nicht zu moderieren können sie nicht zu
moderieren jemand holen der ahnung hat
keck wait ach das hat gerade angefangen oder was die dorfmann ist da schon mal
Leute, ich glaube, das darf man mit Sicherheit nicht restreamen.
Deswegen werde ich das jetzt gar nicht großartig zeigen.
Oh je, oh je.
Der Anfang hört sich mega cringe an, bestimmt.
Einen wunderschönen...
Oh, nee.
Es tut schon weh, wenn ich es höre, was er...
...mit Felix Falk und Andi Scheuer die Begrüßung machen kann.
Und habe auch gleich schon die schlechte Nachricht...
Alter, was hat die am Start da?
...wie der Witze über...
Da haben sie aber genau geguckt, dass das Bein so richtig...
Die hat die Bose wahrscheinlich zwei Stunden geübt vorher.
Dass das Bein genauso in die Lücke hier passt.
Oh, der ist auch am Start.
...im Digitalzeitalter...
Die deutsche Computerspielbranche als Pionier?
Okay, okay.
Na dann.
Ja, weil wir...
Weil wir beim Thema Games wahnsinnig pioniert-rechtig sind.
Wahnsinnig ist alles abgeklebt hier.
Wir gehen auch auf Nummer sicher.
Ja.
Hast du das gesehen?
Hier, der ist für euch.
Riesen Applaus nochmal.
Viele Grüße nach Stuttgart.
Riesen Applaus.
Wer soll denn applaudieren?
Das ist aufstrebend.
Es sollten wir im...
Das ist doch gar keiner da.
Wir freuen uns auf das kommende fröhliche Spiel.
Den kenne ich.
Und wir machen die...
Warte mal, wer ist das nochmal?
...in unserer...
Den kenne ich.
Den habe ich schon mal auf YouTube irgendwo gesehen.
Das ist der High-Five-Typ.
Das ist der ehemalige High-Five-Typ.
Ein, einer von den High-Five-Boys und Grills.
Waren wir mal Game...
Genau, stimmt.
Das ist einer von der GameStar, oder?
Oder von der GamePro?
Nino Kerl.
Alter, heißt es wirklich Kerl?
Ich habe gesagt, das ist der Kerl von der...
Ich meinte das damit so, wie das ist der Typ.
Ich wusste nicht, dass der Kerl heißt.
Der beste Prototyp.
Okay, Leute.
Die fünf Minuten gönnen wir uns noch.
Prim.
Der schwarz-weiße Cartoon-Look ist einzigartig und stilsicher.
Der Gamer muss einen Weg finden, um aus seinem Zimmer zu flüchten
und eine gefährliche Reise durch die Unterwelt antreten.
Sabine, echt?
Das Point-and-Click-Adventure enthält spannende...
Fullscreen.
...hier eine humorvolle Geschichte und ein stimmiges Rätsel-Design.
Sonority.
Ausgestattet mit einer Panflöte macht sich die Spielfigur auf den Weg
durch einen mysteriösen Felsengarten...
...und lernt dabei...
Ah, jetzt geht's.
...die innovative Mechanik verknüpft die Spielumgebung mit der einfachen Musiktheorie
und führt die Spieler an melodische Grundlagen.
What the...
Wild Woods.
Ob das Spaß macht?
Das Koop-Gameplay besticht durch seine stilsichere Grafik und einer hohen Produktionsqualität.
Dabei müssen vier kleine Katzen einen Planwagen vor Gefahren und Feinden beschützen.
Das Spiel verbindet klassischen Mehrspielerspaß mit Roguelike-Elementen.
Äh...
Ach, Prim.
Prim erinnert mich an die guten alten 386er-Zeiten mit den ganzen Pointer-Klick-Adventures.
Monkey Island, Day of the Tentacle, Indiana Jones, Fate of Atlantis...
Haha, wie sie nickt!
Wie sie nickt!
...an diese Zeit.
Ja, ich weiß.
Wie sie nickt.
Ich hab keinen Plan, Alter, was du erzählst.
Ah, yes, excellent.
...schön, dass es vorbei ist und wir heute es doch ein bisschen anspruchsvoller gestaltet haben tatsächlich.
Alter, was ist mit meinem Fullscreen los?
...sind alle bereit?
Die brauchen wir ja überhaupt jetzt mal hier im Bilde.
Fünf Stück sind...
Leider sind sie noch nicht bereit.
Warte.
...wird mir geraten...
...gerade über mein Ohr geflüstert.
Das ist nicht dein Ernst.
Doch, das ist tatsächlich so.
Also, wir können doch noch ein bisschen in der Vergangenheit schwelgen.
Erzähl mal.
Was war denn dein Favorit?
Monkey Island 1, 2 oder 3?
Wozu?
Gute Antwort.
Jetzt haben wir auch alle Nominierten.
Hätten sie nicht...
Hätten sie nicht ihn nehmen können plus noch irgendeinen, der Plan hat?
Was uns jetzt noch fehlt, ist tatsächlich die Laudatio.
Und das Schöne ist, für mich...
Stimmt, wir machen das hier auch.
...man sieht die Gesichter der Nominierten, alle gespannt.
Und am Anfang ist es noch nebulös.
Man weiß nicht, in welche Richtung es geht.
Und irgendwann fällt ein Satz, ein Wort und dann weiß einer...
Ah, ich glaube, es geht um die Freude.
Und dann ist die Freude groß in dem Gesicht.
Also, achtet drauf, wer es diesmal ist.
Wahrscheinlich hat keiner Bock drauf gehabt, das zu moderieren.
...alle fünf ganz großartige Prototypen.
Weil im deutschen Computerspiel...
Der guckt richtig happy hier in der Mitte, der Kerl.
...seichnen wir hier den Sieger mit 35.000 Euro...
Oh, erst mal Verbindungsabbruch.
Erst mal RIP.
Das wäre jetzt lustig.
Das wäre jetzt lustig, wenn der Gewinner...
...Verbindungsabbruch hätte.
Ähm...
Kennt man sie irgendwoher?
Ich habe sie noch nicht gesehen bisher.
Die DDoS ist raus.
...wenn sie in der Welt erkennbar hochwertig umgesetzt.
Ein Spiel, das sich deutlich abhebt...
...durch die originelle und stilsichere optische Präsentation.
Der Nachwuchspreis für den besten...